Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Christian
hey.
Yes.
Hey,
>> that
>> Thank you.
Good evening, friends, and welcome as we
gather in.
My name is Cat. My pronouns are she and
her. And we are grateful that you are
here with us in person or online.
Whether this is your first time with us
or you've called this community home for
years, whether you're coming whether
you're coming from today full of faith,
full of questions, or somewhere in
between,
your presence means everything to us.
We have a couple of announcements to
share with you. For all of these, you
can scan the QR code and get any
additional information.
Our next welcome to the table class
is very excited about that. Class
is April 19th, which is next Sunday.
It's before service. If you are new to
the table, this is an opportunity to
learn about our community, our values,
our mission, and to ask any questions
that you may have about us.
We have an accessibility bucket over
there on that little table. If you are a
bit anxious about being in church or a
church setting today, we have available
for you at the table there are
noiseancelling headphones, fidgets, and
coloring sheets. We just ask that you
return them on your way out.
As we begin,
I invite you to close your eyes
and to take in a deep breath.
And now out,
settling into the peace
and stillness
of God.
These candles
are a symbol
of the mystery of the loving presence of
Christ among us. A mystery that we do
not control contain, but rather one that
meets us in our unknowing
and gently invites us toward healing
and wholeness.
Now we exit the world of noise
and productivity.
And now we enter the realm of silence,
stillness
and simplicity,
sacred space.
A place of prayer,
worship,
adoration.
A place to behold Christ.
Revelation of God. Heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace
find you. Mend your heart.
May we find ourselves at last
home.
Thank you, Cat. If you guys want to
stand with us, we're going to get
started with the worship again tonight.
And uh this morning, I was listening to
a song that we uh kind of started the
table with. Actually, it was our very
first song to ever play in our very
first service um called Ring the Bells.
And one of the lines in that song stood
out to me again. And it says, "His
mercies won't be rationed here." That's
what we're fighting for. And I just
loved that reminder that there's no
rationing of God's mercy. There is
plenty. There is an abundance. There is
an overflowing amount for each one of us
as we walk into this space. We offer
that to ourselves and to one another.
The mercy of God, the spirit of God, her
love is flowing and it is in abundance
tonight for each one of us here. So, um,
let's enjoy that as we sing together.
Sometimes on this journey journey. Get
lost in my mistakes.
What looks to me like weakness is a
canvas for your strength.
My story isn't over. My story's just
begun.
Fail. You won't define me. That's what
my father does.
my father does. Ooh.
Lay your burdens down. Ooh.
Here in the Father's house. Check your
shame at the door. It ain't welcome
anymore.
You're in the father's house. Woo.
Arrival's not the end game. The
journey's where you are.
You never want it perfect. You just
wanted my heart.
And the story isn't over. at the story
isn't good enough. Failures never final
when the father's in the room. I said
failures never final when the father's
in the room. Wo wo
lay your burdens down. Wo wo
here in the father's house. Check your
shame at the door. Say ain't welcome
anymore. Wo wo.
You're in the father's house.
The father's house. In the father's
arms.
Prodigals come home.
Helpless find hope.
Love is on the move when the father's in
the room.
Prison doors swing wide.
Dead come to life.
Love is on the move when the father's in
the room.
Miracles take place.
Cynical finds place.
Love is breaking through when the
father's in the room. Yeah.
Mirles wall was breaking.
Strongholds now are shaking.
Love is breaking through and the
father's in the room.
Love is breaking through when the
father's in the room. Oh wo.
Lay your burdens down. Oh wo.
Here in the father's house, check your
shame at the door. Is any welcome
anymore.
Oh wo.
You're in the father's house.
No shame here. No fear here.
All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to their classrooms with their
teachers and they will meet them right
over there by those double doors.
Thank you, Abby and Kaitlyn.
Maitlyn,
Katie,
Kaylee,
Harper, Maddie, all the people who are
helping back there in those classrooms.
We're so grateful for you guys.
>> All right, and we're going to transition
into the prayers of the people. Um, if
this is your first time with us tonight,
this is a tradition that was passed down
through Christian history that we're
joining in with just to acknowledge what
we carry into this space. Any pain, um,
loss, discomfort, we just want to speak
those out loud. So, we're going to read
aloud the parts in red together that are
on the screen, and then we'll pause for
a brief u moment in the middle for you
to offer up and speak out loud a name or
a situation that you're carrying on your
heart tonight. And then we'll close the
prayer together again.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you. Lord, we know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you,
Johnny Owen,
Nana,
Jennifer
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace in a deep sense
of your presence.
Amen.
Come to the river
all who are thirsty.
Come and drink.
Come to the table
all who are hungry.
Come and feast
those who are wey,
those who are needy.
Come receive.
Come to the river.
Taste and see.
Come to the water
all who are thirsty.
Come and drink.
Come to the table.
All who are hungry.
Come and feed
those who are wey,
those who are needy.
Come receive.
Come to the river.
days and see.
Oh,
oh, my soul
thirst for you
and you alone.
Oh.
Oh my soul,
thirst for you.
You alone. Oh my soul. Oh.
Oh my soul
thirst for you
in you alone.
Oh
my soul,
thirst for you
and you alone.
I will taste
and see that you are good.
You're good to me.
I will taste
and see that you are good.
and see that you are good. Oh, I will
taste
and see that you are good.
You're good to me.
Oh my soul,
thirst for you.
You alone.
Oh.
Oh my soul
thirst for you.
You alone.
Come to the water
all who are thirsty.
Come and drink.
Come to the table.
All who are hungry.
Come and feast.
Sing this together.
We love you.
We'll never stop. We can't live without
you.
Jesus,
we love you
and we can't get enough.
All this is for you,
Jesus.
When you walk into the room,
everything changes
and darkness starts to tremble at the
light that you bring when you walk into
the room.
Every heart starts burning. And nothing
matters more than just to sit here at
your feet and worship you.
We worship you.
Oh,
when you walk into the room,
sickness starts to vanish. Every
hopeless situation
ceases to exist. And when you walk into
the room,
the dead begins to rise. Cuz there is
resurrection life in all you do.
We love you.
We'll never stop. We can't live without
you, Jesus.
We love you
and we can't get enough.
All this is for you, Jesus.
Jesus.
So come and consume God. Oh, we are. We
give you permission. Our hearts are
yours. We want you.
We want you
to come and consume, God. All we are. We
give you permission. Our hearts are
yours. We want you.
>> We want you
to come and consume God. All we are.
give you permission. Our hearts are
yours. We want you.
We want you
to come and consume God. All we are. We
give you permission. Our hearts are
yours. We want you.
We want you.
We love you.
We'll never stop. We can't live without
you,
Jesus.
We love you.
And we can't get enough
of this for you, Jesus.
We love you,
children.
Can't live without you, Jesus.
We love you.
And we can't get enough.
It's for you, Jesus.
Jesus.
God, thank you for being enough.
that your love and your grace is enough.
That it doesn't run out. It doesn't run
dry.
We can't escape it.
Even in our distraction, our
forgetfulness, or even our wewardness,
God, it pursues us. It follows us.
It sustains us.
God, tonight we sink ourselves into that
truth
that you are always with us.
You are always calling us back to your
heart.
Your love is always available.
No matter what we've done,
no matter who we've been,
God, would you awaken us to your love?
Would it get first place in our heart,
in our homes, in our lives, in our jobs,
in our relationships? Would it be the
thing that guides us
and leads us forward?
We love you. We cannot get enough of
your love.
It's in your name that we pray all these
things and thank you for this time
together in Jesus name. Amen.
All
right. Would you guys turn to the person
on your right and left and say, "The
peace of Christ be with you." And then
Brett will get us started on our
message.
Here
we go. Oh,
too much. Too much. All right. Sorry. I
I think I clicked it the wrong way. Um,
struggling. I think this is my first
time, but it's not.
Well, welcome everyone. My name is
Brett. I'm the pastor here and yeah, a
joy joy to be with you in this space and
uh to welcome you and that uh includes
join us online. Love you a lot. Not
forgotten and anyone here tonight who is
new this your first time or maybe just
your first time in a while. Uh we're
just really really glad that you're here
among us and uh I know it can take a lot
of courage to come through those those
double doors. Um I say this often that
you know it's pretty rare the person who
comes into this this church space to the
table and has had nothing but a
delightful experience with church
communities. That's a that's a rare
person. So if you're uh you know entered
into this space a little trepidation
just know um yeah we're really really
glad that you're that you're here. So,
um, you've come on a good night because
we're kicking off a new series tonight
and, uh, it's titled Holy Resilience:
Understanding the Trauma Behind
Scripture. And, uh, it's inspired by a
book of the same, at least title, not
subtitle, but the that name Holy
Resilience uh, by David M. Carr. And uh
I was actually kind of pointed in this
direction by the table's own Charles
Kaiser uh who does a lot of work with um
he has an organization called the
healing collective. Um he's not here
tonight but um his nonprofit does work
basically with folks recovering from
spiritual trauma. So he has a a
substack. I think it's called the
empathetic witness if you want to Google
it. And it's a wonderful substack. And
so I read it often. And he was talking
and he had an article on this book. And
so I was like woo this sounds like a
this sounds like a good one. So, I
checked it out and I was like, "Oh,
yeah. I'm going to do a series on this."
So, um I I hope it will um be kind of
inspiring, insightful, helpful, and um
as we kind of go through this over the
next few weeks. So, the title of my
message is Trauma and the Judgment of
God. And uh it'll serve as kind of a
series intro. The first half will be
kind of a series intro and then we'll
get into some specifics. Um so, to kind
of start here, where I want to begin is
to kind of unpack um two questions.
first you know what what's the meaning
uh what do we mean by this word trauma
and then second uh what do I mean by
this understanding the trauma behind
scripture which in ways you know that'll
be like the whole series we'll be
unpacking what we mean there um so we'll
start with this first key question you
know what do what do I mean by trauma uh
because you know this is obviously it's
a word it's a popular word in culture
you know if you haven't noticed uh it is
everywhere and uh you know that's kind
of inevitable right as a as a word kind
of makes its way into the the collective
ive you know culture it kind of gets
watered down you know to where it's like
uh in a way you know everything in some
circles like everything is trauma and uh
so just to be clear I don't think you
know all adversity is trauma if you've
been through a hard experience it's
traumatizing you know not necessarily uh
instead really trauma is something quite
specific so we'll define it like this
psychological trauma is a person's uh
experience of emotional distress
resulting from an event that overwhelms
their capacity to emotionally digest it
I think the key word there is overwhelm
homes, right? So, when you're not able
to process a thing, that's where the
nervous system can get kind of stuck and
uh it can become really problematic. So,
this is why there's a difference between
adversity and trauma, right? You can
like well, adversity is something that's
hard, right? You go through something
very hard and challenging, but as long
as you're able to like work through it,
well, then that's what you do. You know
what I mean? kind of talk it through,
work it through, and it's sort of like
processes, you know, through the nervous
system and out. It's kind like, okay,
I'm beyond that, you know, maybe it took
a day or a week or a month or what, but
like, okay, moving forward, and it feels
good. You know, you don't feel this kind
of residual triggering every time you're
back in some set, you know? Um whereas
uh trauma is different, right? This is
why Gabbor Mate, he defines trauma as
intense suffering processed in
isolation. Another definition he offers
is trauma is not what happens to you but
what happens inside of you as a response
to pain you couldn't process at the
time. So you can see here kind of this
connection between like pain
isolation
processing where it's much more likely
you will struggle to process a thing
when you feel captured in sort of
aloneeness. You know what I It's like I
mean I guess it could be done perhaps
through a lot of journaling and prayer
and you know or something but like it's
a very hard thing generally the way we
process a thing is verbally emotionally
you know we kind of this is where um
this term the empathetic witness will
become um kind of important as we go on
uh it's it's really that's where we
start to process something or we talk
with someone and we and they meet us
there and that's like oh it's so healing
you know to process it through and uh so
if you give people that like oh my gosh
like we can go, you know, through hell
and like come out the other side and
it's not just this kind of, you know,
death sentence of like I'm just
traumatized forever, you know, like you
really can through the months and years,
you know, you can work it through and
get to a a new place, you know. So
that's that's the the beautiful thing.
So that's what I mean by um trauma is
this kind of an really significant
nervous system shock that for various
reasons kind of gets stuck and you're
not able to process it well. Maybe it's
because you're, you know, the sense of
hiding or you just I couldn't talk about
this, you know, whatever. And uh and it
it gets stuck in that in that way. Um
so, okay. So, what about the second
question? You know, what is this the
understanding the trauma behind
scripture behind, you know, the Bible?
What's that getting at? Well, to kind of
get at this, let me back up a little bit
and say, I think in a lot of ways, as
kind of well, I'll say culture, I think,
is trying to kind of process the
information that trauma studies have
kind of put out there. And so
like it's sort of like almost every
sphere of society is trying to kind of
take this on board and become more quote
unquote trauma informed, right? So I
mean there's moves for like educators to
be more trauma informed where the the
principal and the teachers and certainly
the school counselors you know to learn
about trauma so that they can kind of
and when they're interacting with a
student and it's like things are getting
really sideways they can start to pick
up on certain things of like is this
just kind of like a bad day or is this
like is something else deeper going on
here? Am I talking actually interacting
with a traumatized person right now? And
this isn't going to be as simple as
like, oh, just have a conversation or
two, you know, like what what's going on
here? So, there's a move, you know, for
educators to do this. Um there's a move
of course for like social workers and
first responders and even HR departments
you know to like just learn kind of take
this on board probably like oh okay
trauma is a real thing you know and this
this changes how we like interact
potentially with someone if they've you
know been through traumatic experiences
and such and uh I mean I've noticed even
uh dentists they're becoming more traum
Believe it or not, some of you are like,
"Not my dentist." You know, but this is
like a thing where I remember like when
my kids were super young and going
through some of their, you know, in the
early days where like the dentist is
like really scary and difficult and they
like had some bad teeth and it was like
a whole thing. And I remember we went to
this like special dentist. We're going
to do this procedure and he's like, "I'm
so sorry." Um cuz one of our kids was
like kind of freaking out and like I'm
so sorry, but um we are not going to be
able to proceed with this procedure
today. uh there and they literally
explained to me like there have been
studies we can legitimately like
especially younger kids are prone to
like get trauma and then I mess them up
for like it can be difficult when they
go back to a dentist for the rest of
their life and so for that reason I'm
sorry we're going to have to transfer
you or we're going to set up an
appointment at you know children's
medical and it was like a whole thing
you know so that's like an example of
where even dentists are like you know
it's not the 1960s anymore okay you know
what I mean we're just like hey just get
the drill you know um so this is all you
know kind of in the in the water so to
speak even churches, right? Um there's a
move to try to they go to seminary and
such. They like start to teach you about
spiritual trauma and such like this is
kind of a you know a thing. And so, you
know, kind of my aha moment when reading
Carr's book was that I realized that
while, you know, I'm all for advocating
for like, you know, trauma-informed
education and trauma-informed dentistry
and trauma-informed parenting and
trauma-informed pastoral care and
trauma-informed small group leadership
and, you know, and so on and so on. What
had never ever occurred to me was a
trauma-informed reading of the Bible.
this had not occurred to me. And and
it's sort of one of those things that
once you kind of see it, you can't unsee
it. It's like so glaringly obvious, but
I don't know how, but it just like it
was kind of that sometimes that's the
beauty of right authors, right? They
give you that aha moment where you can
kind of see the thing clearly and it's
like, oh my gosh, this is so how did I
not not see this? So, okay. So, what do
I what do I mean um by this
trauma-informed reading of the Bible? Do
I mean, you know, the Bible will
traumatize you? Uh, I mean perhaps, but
no, that's not generally what I have in
mind. Instead, what I mean is you can't
really understand the Bible if you don't
understand that it's actually born, it's
birthed from this place. Much of it is
born from traumatic suffering. The
authors themselves
uh went through much more than we tend
to be tracking.
Put it a little bit differently, we
could say the Bible, it just makes a lot
more sense once you get that it came
from traumatized communities.
Communities who suffered tremendously
and as we talked about earlier struggled
to process that pain.
You see the library of writings that now
make up you know what we know as the
Bible. It's interesting. We think of it
as like one book but of course it's a
library. it's this across generations
and a lot of time you know um this
collection of writings that we call the
Bible um you know it was far from like
the most popular religious literature of
its of its day it was just this little I
don't know maybe in our minds you know
ancient Israel was like this giant
powerful empire you know but if you look
at it on like the stage of world history
it was just this little backwater and so
aside from a kind of maybe a small
little um golden era um it pretty much a
marginal kind of place. You know,
ancient Jerusalem was maybe 20,000
people at its like absolute peak, you
know, so it was just like a a kind of
small place. Um, and yet the the
writings of scripture uh inspired today,
I mean, two major world religions, it's
millions of people all over the world um
still read and study this text. What
what's going on here? Well, this is kind
of the upside to it is that generations
of readers resonate with the Bible
because it's a text born from trauma and
suffering. Right? In other words, most
religious writings we have from way back
when was kind of uh it was it came from
empires
whose gods kind of sponsored their
violence.
And
so the the Bible is interesting in that
because it's it's coming from, you know,
the Jewish community, it's uh actually
it's a text that somehow survived
even though it's technically written
from the perspective of the quote
unquote losers. Right? We've all heard
this phrase that, you know, the winners
get to write history, right? Have you
ever heard this like it's a right and
that's why it's preserved and passed on
is the winners win and then they destroy
everything else. You don't really get
the perspective of the loser so to
speak, right? But that's the thing with
the Bible is it was like miracle of
miracles. It was this dominated
traumatized community and yet the
scriptures kind of persisted.
And so um the thing is though the Bible
records a kind of primal memory of a
kind of Egyptian enslavement
uh and then later the Assyrian conquest
and then the Babylonian conquest and
then the Persians took over for the
Babylonians and then you had the Greek
conquest and then by the time you come
to the New Testament it's the Roman
conquest. So, it's basically one
national catastrophe after another. And
if you've read either the entire Bible
or at least portions of it, then you've
probably kind of caught on that like,
oh, these conquests like this factors
very prominently in the the history and
in the the writing, right? It informs
the writers so much. In other words, the
Bible is born not just from pain and not
just from hard times, but but really it
it's born from traumatized communities.
You see, conquest and exile in the
ancient world was absolutely brutal.
Like this is where we can read, you
know, the prophets, which we'll get to
in a bit, and we can read certain lines
about, oh, then the Babylonians came and
they they wiped us out or that, you
know, and we just kind of like, okay,
cool, cool, cool. what's next? You know,
it's like whoa, that's like there's a
whole history there. There's a whole
thing going on in the background there
that we're just Does that make sense?
We're just not quite tuned in. It's just
kind of words on a page for us. But for
them, I mean, to hear the whole nations
conquered. I mean, it's just it's an
absolute disaster. It means fathers and
parents killed before your very eyes. I
mean, it means people raped. It means
children or killed. And then if you
were, you know, lucky enough to survive,
well, half the town, anyone with money,
education, skills, the empire takes
them, scatters them all over, exiles
them. Then if you're one of the ones
who's left in the land because you're
poor, don't have the skills, whatever.
Well, now you're dealing with like not
only the trauma of what just happened,
but like famine and you're living in
this war torn region. I mean, it's a
hellscape. It's like absolutely awful,
right? And so like like in essence um
this again it wasn't just a hard day,
right? This was war and terror and loss
at the highest levels. And so kind of
the the point I'm getting at is that so
much of the Old Testament, even some of
the New has been shaped by a people who
experience that not just once or twice,
but in generation after generation after
generation. And and this on the upside,
this is partly again why we resonate
with it, right? I mean, books like Job,
the Psalms of Lament, the book of
Lamentations. I mean, literally, it's
the book of Lamentations, the book of
Lament, the book of, you know, what's
going on? Why where's this book just
popping up? It's the It's after the
Babylonian conquest. It's people saying,
"Oh my god. Oh my god." Like they're
freaking out. They can't. It's grief and
loss and pain, right? And this is what
people resonate, right? Again, because
it's not just written written from the
perspective of the winners. It's written
from the loser. It's written from those
who've been beaten down and trod down.
And you know, this is where we
generation after generation resonates
with the scriptures, right? It's like,
yeah, I can kind of process my own
grief, my own pain. I see it there kind
of mirrored back to me.
However, this is where things get more
complicated because yes, we relate to
the Bible because it's a text born from
trauma and suffering.
However, many of us are repelled by
parts of the Bible because it's a text
born from trauma and suffering. In other
words, for every Christian I know who is
just a scripture person, they just love
it. They just love the Bible and they're
just like, "Yeah, you know, uh there is
another person who's just like,
I don't do that." You know, they're a
Christian. They love Jesus. still maybe
even read the gospels or something, you
know, but like the Bible as a whole
just, you know, they say uh something
like I've read the Bible, you know, some
of it's good. You know, Genesis is cool.
The Psalms are nice. At least a lot of
the Psalms,
not all of them.
Here's a here's an example. This is
Psalm 137. And again, kind of as you
tune in to the trauma-informed reading
of the Bible, notice the context here.
By the rivers of Babylon we sat and wept
when we remembered Zion.
There on the poplars it's like I guess
trees we hung our harps for there our
capttors asked us for songs. Our
tormentors demanded songs of joy. They
said sing us one of the songs of Zion.
It's another name for Jerusalem.
Sing us one of the songs of Zion. Oh,
how can we sing the songs of the Lord
while in a foreign land? Remember, Lord,
what the did on the day
Jerusalem fell.
Tear it down, they cried. Tear it down
to its foundations, oh daughter Babylon,
doomed to destruction. Happy is the one
who repays you according to what you
have done to us. Happy is the one who
seizes your infants and dashes them
against the rocks. Right? This is the
kind of psalm where people read the
Bible like I'm going to my morning
devotions, you know, and they read
someone, they're just like, "What is
going on? I can't make sense of this."
Or like, "Is this good? Is this like
good? Is this this is holy or what? I
don't Does that make sense?" Like where
where people get confused. This is where
I think a trauma-informed reading of the
Bible really helps and be like, "Oh,
you see what kind of a person would say
that they want to take babies and
infants and do something like this?"
Perhaps a traumatized person, perhaps
someone whose little baby or infant that
was done to.
Right? This is the the the kind of
primal wounds and pain that the Bible
came from. But it's not just a few
random psalms. In fact, where I'm going
to focus on the rest of this this
message is to kind of on the image of
God that emerges from some of these
passages uh and from people in pain. And
so I want to talk about the prophets,
you know, for all of their strengths.
And there are some wonderful I think
strengths of the the prophet. Thinking
of prophets like books like Isaiah,
Amos, Hezekiah, um lots all those name
books in the Old Testament, Obadai, like
there's all sorts. um for all their
strengths. The one of the more
problematic aspects of the prophets um
is that they they attribute the horrible
violent acts of these evil empires like
Assyria and Babylon. They ascribe it um
to the very will of God.
Uh let's look at a few examples of this.
Here's Isaiah 10:es 5-6.
Woe to the Assyrian,
the rod of my anger, in whose hand is
the club of my wrath. I send him against
a godless nation. The prophet says, I
dispatch him against a people who anger
me to seize loot and snatch plunder and
to trample them down like mud in the
streets.
So notice here like
the conquering empire of Assyria is the
rod of my anger. And who's the godless
nation?
Is it Assyria?
No, it's Israel
there. We'll get more into this next
week for the kind of self-lame stuff.
But but who is the godless nation? Not
the terrible Assyrians. No, it's the
Israelites. In other words, when Assyria
comes in conquering, torturing, raping,
destroying, Isaiah is saying, "Asi,
that's the divine will that moves them.
Assyria is a club or a rod in the hand
of God." Now, I don't know how that
strikes you, but for me, it strikes me
as incredibly problematic. uh a a very
problematic image of God to say who is
or or that God would will intentionally
will that you know it's just like ah
yikes. Uh here's Amos 5:6. Seek the Lord
and live
or he will sweep through the tribes of
Joseph like a fire. It will devour them.
Bethl will have no one to quench it. So
again here the destruction it's not just
random acts of violence in a sometimes
awful world. dominated by, you know,
empires of every type in in this case
the Assyrian Empire. No, no. God in the
form of the Assyrians or moving the, you
know, Babylon uh the Babylonians will
sweep through Israel like a fire. Or
finally, here's um Ezekiel 16:30-31 and
then verse 43. I'm filled with fury
against you, declares the sovereign
Lord. When you do all these things,
acting like a brazen prostitute. When
you built your mounds at every street
corner, made your lofty shrines in every
public square. You were unlike a
prostitute. Because you scorned payment,
because you did not remember the days of
your youth, but enraged me with all
these things, I will surely bring down
on your head what you've done, declares
the sovereign Lord. I mean, you can kind
of feel there, right? The the energy,
the abuse, the violence in a passage
like this. So it's it's problematic and
disturbing and this is why we kind of
end up with these kind of groups in the
church of you know scripture people and
then those who are just like I don't do
this you know not just not down with
this. So what does that mean? Well if
you've been at the table for a while um
you know I think we we need to think of
and approach the Bible differently. Uh
I've mentioned this quote before but
I'll read it again. It feels timely.
This is the theologian and former church
uh leader of the church of England,
Rowan Williams. He put it like this. He
said, "One of the great tragedies and
errors of the way people have understood
the Bible has been the assumption that
what people did in the Old Testament or
I would add to that even what they said
in the Old Testament must have been
right because it's in the Bible. It's
justified violence, enslavement, abuse,
and suppression of women, murderous
prejudice against gay people. It has
justified all manner of things we now
cannot but as Christians regard as evil.
But they are not there in the Bible
because God is telling us that's good.
They're there because God is telling us
you need to know that that is how some
people responded. You need to know
here's the key that when I speak to
human beings things can go very wrong as
well as very wonderfully.
God tells us, "You need to know that
when I speak, it isn't always simple to
hear because of what human beings are
like." We need, in other words, to guard
against the temptation to take just a
bit of the whole story and treat it as
somehow a model for our own behavior.
Christians have often been down that
road, and it has not been a pretty
sight. We need rather to approach the
Bible as if it were a parable of Jesus.
The whole thing is a gift, a challenge,
and an invitation into a new world.
Seeing yourself aresh and more
truthfully.
Now, where I find cars work so helpful
here is I think it gives us a kind of
framework. It allows us to be uh less
negative and less judgmental of the
biblical writers. See, because kind of
following Williams, we could get a
little judgy, you know, we could say
like, "Can you believe those people? How
could they write stuff like that? That
was like an awful image of God." and
that's in the Bible and well maybe I'm
just throwing all this I don't even know
with this whole Christian faith it's
just all a hot mess and you know you can
see where we could kind of
um
or
we could say you know I wonder how
traumatized that person was you know I
wonder what they were going through and
I wonder how their trauma pushed them
pushed them in a direction that here's
the key in the short term was actually
helpful for them but in the long term
kind of messed up their and our image of
God. Uh what do I mean? Well again Carr
writes he says this. My colleague and
the president of my seminary Serena
Jones put it well when she said to one
of my classes for many who suffer deeply
the only thing that frightens them more
than the idea that God is punishing them
is the idea that God is not in charge at
all.
I think that's a real revelation and an
eyeopener
and uh so to kind of close here I see at
least two kind of implications or like
takeaways from this because I realize
that's like a lot of words and ideas and
such. So what do we do to kind of you
know take away from this? Number one,
like ancient Israel, many Christians
today, particularly those who have
suffered deeply often cling to images of
God as in control of everything and
everyone in very specific ways. I would
call this and kind of use therapy
language is a kind of anxious attachment
to God.
In other words, they find a certain
comfort in this image of God, right?
It's kind of comforting to say it was
the Lord's will. That horrible, awful
thing that was that was God's will. In
fact, God brought that into my life to
we'll get more into this next week, but
either to teach me a lesson or to get me
back on the right track or to you know,
we and we kind of make sense of it um in
that way. So, it's kind of comforting to
say, "Ah, everything that happens was
intentionally willed and wanted it and
decreed by God. even my traumatic
experiences, you know, everything from
tornadoes to cancer to whatever you
know, it they say, "Oh, it's the divine
will." I mean, there was a kind of
somewhat infamous um article written by
John Piper back in 2012. He talked about
described that the the there was a
number like 50 tornadoes across like 12
states and like hundreds of people died.
It was like this whole massacre and he
said it's the very finger of God. That
was the the will of God, you know, like
honestly that's he was critiqued. That's
no different than what Isaiah is saying
here. You know what I mean? Like it it's
biblical, quote unquote. It's just
problematic, right? It's just not very
Christlike. So, this is difficult,
right? And so, on the one hand, it helps
people grapple. On the other hand, we
may end up kind of entering into a kind
of um I don't know, almost a cringing,
subservient, almost abusive relationship
with God, right? Almost like how you
might bargain with or manipulate an
abusive parent where you're kind of like
vacasillating between, you know, like it
was all my fault, it was all my fault or
this kind of um manipulating controlling
God and God's will and such. So, in the
end though, I'd say that's just not the
most emotionally healthy form of
attachment to God to put it mildly. Um,
so that's the first takeaway. Second
takeaway, many progressive or
deconstructing Christians can grow quite
exasperated with their Christian
siblings who cling to images of God as
an angry tyrant. A trauma-informed
approach to faith in scripture can help
us be more curious and compassionate
about what may drive that anxious style
of attachment.
I think honestly this is something um
well this could be at two levels. For
one, for me, this was helpful because I
started to think of my own relationship
with God and to kind of reflect on where
am I? Have I maybe slipped into that at
times in this kind of almost abusive
relationship? Like I do feel like that's
something I'm kind of slowly over like
20 years kind of healing from on my own
journey there. Um, but the second part
of that as well, like I also though find
myself maybe because I even struggle
with it personally, then getting judgy
and upset at other Christians, right?
were just like, "Ah, how could you view
God like that? How could that's so
problematic?" And you know, and instead
of approaching them with um a kind of
curiosity and uh a compassion, right?
Instead of being shocked and offended
and upset at people, um this I think can
help reframe it where we get curious
about people's histories and like what
have they been through that would lead
them to, you know, engage with God and
think of God in such ways. So, and I
think in the end, you know, anything
that's nudging us towards patience,
towards compassion
to other people, um, I think that's the
work of the Holy Spirit. And so, my my
kind of prayer is throughout this
series, may we all come to approach
scripture, uh, approach ourselves,
approach others, uh, with kind of new
and more gentle, um, eyes. In the name
of the Father, the Son, and the Holy
Spirit. Amen.
So on the night before his death, Jesus
took bread and he gave thanks and he
broke it and he said, "This is my body.
It's given for you."
After supper, he took the cup and he
said, "This is my blood poured out for
you. Whenever you share this, remember
me." And so tonight, we proclaim the
mystery of faith. Christ has died.
Christ is risen. And Christ will come
again.
The way we'll uh go about taking
communion tonight is we'll just go rowby
row, starting here at the front and kind
of working our way back. We'll just form
one line in the middle. So when one row
is kind of done, the next one can, you
know, jump in. Uh we practice what's
called an open table here. So if you'd
like to participate uh to partake of the
the bread and the cup, you're you're
welcome to do that. uh regardless of
your exact like, you know, theology or
denomination or whatever. If you're here
and you want to participate and connect
with Christ in this way, you're free to
do that. Um at the same time, there's no
pressure. If you're not comfortable
doing that, that's that's fine, too. Uh
just know the red is wine, the white is
grape juice. And uh finally, once the
officians kind of hand you um the
elements, you can partake of them
immediately or you can some people like
to come and kneel here at the front,
some return to their seats. You can
partake whenever and however you'd like.
So this is the table not of the church
but of the Lord. And it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come you who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you who feel like
you failed. Come. Come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself who invites you. And
it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
Gracious God,
we thank you for this holy mystery.
We thank you for meeting us here and
feeding us with your love. Send us out,
God, renewed by your Holy Spirit to give
ourselves to others.
Amen.
If you guys would like to stand with us,
we're going to close with um a song
called Come Tear Down the Walls. And as
we kind of maybe look back on our own
journey with faith, with Jesus, with
scripture
um and look at the areas where we may be
carrying our own trauma into it or for
forgetting to see the trauma of others
that have informed it. Let's just hold
our hearts open before God, trusting
that he is good and his love is good and
it can sustain us.
Come tear down the walls built up. Every
wall I built up. Every wall I built up.
Cuz you deserve every piece of my heart.
Every piece of my heart. Every piece of
my heart. Lord,
I am trusting that you are a faithful
father and all that you have it is good.
You're a generous giver. Your love's
like no other. Won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again? I am bringing my heart to you
with openness.
Closer and closer. You're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again.
Over and over and over again. I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer. You're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again.
Lord,
I am trusting that you are a faithful
father and all that you have it is good.
You're a generous giver. You love like
no other. Won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again? I am bringing my heart to you
with open hands.
Closer and closer. You're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again.
Over and over and over again, I am
bringing my heart to you with open
hands.
Closer and closer, you're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again.
Come and tear down the walls I built up.
Every wall I build up. Every wall I've
built up. Cuz you deserve every piece of
my heart. Every piece of my heart. Every
piece of my heart. Come and tear down
the walls I built up. Every wall I built
up. Every wall I built up. Cuz you
deserve every piece of my heart. Every
piece of my heart. Every piece of my
heart.
a small group, attending a table event,
supporting the table financially, or if
you're new and would be willing willing
to fill out a visitor card so we can
have record of your visit. You can take
any of those steps by scanning the QR
code and filling out the appropriate
link. Or you can go the old school way
and go over to that little table and
fill it out and drop it into that little
box
um that you got the same ones that you
entered through.
And now I would like to send you out
into your week with this blessing. You
can hold your hands out in a posture to
receive
or just open your hearts to these words.
You are a child of God.
You
are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day. So
as you go into your week ahead with its
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved.
You are worthy.
You are accepted
just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed and
we'll see you next Sunday.
Over and over and over again, I am
bringing my heart to you with open
hands. Closer and closer you drawing me
in. As the depths of my heart lay before
you again,
over and over and over again. I am
bringing my heart to you with open
hands. Closer and closer. You're drawing
me in as the depths of my heart. Hey,
before you came